it seems to me that Instagram is
designed for me to show everybody else
in the world and it seems to be
particularly acute when it comes to
young women mm-hmm
exactly how amazing my life is and if
I'm only sharing these incredible
moments here I am at Coachella and Here
I am at Burning Man and here's my outfit
is my next outfit this is the hedonic
treadmill that is unhealthy in a way how
do you how do you how do you think about
that because I think about it as a
parent like daughters well I agree with
you however I think it's it's
acknowledged that that's what it is and
by this generation especially and even
the next you know a lot of Gen Z I've
been setting gen Z a lot because they're
our next audience
Cinzia was born between 1995 and 2010
so the oldest of them are graduating
college this year Wow and their consumer
patterns are so different than
millenials huh so Jen Z largely grew up
with technology from day one meaning
like internet devices laptops even
phones at for some of them but beyond
that you know they are the most
resilient generation they grew up
through 9/11 through the recession
they've had bullying their whole life
because since they did online bullying
Bob yeah and in fact they're the most
positive generation that exists and
which is so interesting 70% of them like
in a number there were like 30 different
characteristic traits 70% said pop they
were positive and and and beyond that I
do think that the long tail of Gen Z is
something that I'm thinking about a lot
it has to do a customization but also I
think for businesses and investors it's
really important because this generation
has for instance 58 sexual orientations
they can choose from from Facebook they
am sorry you said 5 8 or 5858 okay I
know 5 yeah and now I could actually do
8 I think I could do it because there's
straight straight yay yeah trans or
queer that's me okay and then that
there's non-binary and then I don't want
to select these other yeah there's cars
are cool
there's words that I don't I can't even
pronounce I think I'm up to that and I
know Facebook now after the eight yeah
it's like it's like their gender
preferences sexual orientations okay cuz
Nick backward um no this is on top of
that too so there's you know blacks akin
is a phrase that people use a lot as
America has gotten more diverse you know
of course so of all this these following
generations so you add all these things
together that's demographics alone right
psychographics this generation has had
internet since they were little so you
know in my mind when I grew up we had
loners at high school who were kind of
interested in weird things no one really
to hang out with fiction has everyone
right they they can find if they're
interested in some really weird hobby
that no one at their school is they have
a community online that's probably still
interested in that and so there's this
long tail of interest and anything that
they've been interested in they just
research about on YouTube and they
figure it out and learn more about it so
they're well informed they're interested
in Reverse they're diverse
demographically like because of that
personalization not just from what their
preferences are and and brands and you
know products but also how they're
getting content sent to them is so
important and I I'm looking at this like
okay I'm a media company trying to build
you know something I'm pioneering
something about all these TV networks
and print companies are like way behind
on already how are you gonna reach this
next generation when I need to probably
make a thousand different pieces of
content of the same piece of content and
target them and then different way of
business of Britain Co it all starts
with the content